[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships retel Cruz number one
bestselling author host of The Rachel
crw show co-host of the smart money
happy hour on the remsey networks and my
daughter is my co-host today open phones
at8 825
5225 we're going to talk about you right
in front of you Dwight starts off this
hour in Seattle hi Dwight how are you
I'm doing okay how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's
up so I'm going through divorce right
now um I've got no money saved my bank
accounts are actually negative I'm about
40,000 in debt and I'm just trying to
figure out where to start I've only
recently started listening to your
podcast I'm sorry how long were you
married uh 5 years what's your
income so right now I work at the post
office um I make and I also have a side
job at applebe I do once a week on my
day off from the post office so I make
roughly five to six, a month right now
why do you have no
money
everything was basically going
into my past living
situation and then we were kind of
arguing for a while and then kind of
came to head and they kicked me out and
so I had to sign a lease which hit up
most of my last
paycheck
okay Dwight is the divorce is it final
not yet not yet
okay no um how old are you 24 okay
probably 25 on Thanksgiving Day
wow okay um the the we've done I've done
and Ramsey has done crisis Financial
counseling Dwight for almost 40 years
and one of the things I've learned to do
when I'm in these kinds of situations or
when I'm helping somebody like you
that's in a situation like this is we
need to uh boil this down to um the next
right three or four things
and not worry about the big stuff off in
the distance right now because right now
you've got some very immediate things
that you need to address and I really
don't care about your retirement
investing right now you follow me it's
not a big deal we'll get we'll get to
that later but and uh but right now we
need stuff like a positive bank balance
uh and no more no more hot checks going
out the door no no more overdraft fees
going out the door right now we need to
make sure the lights and the water are
on in the apartment and the apartments
paid and um you sounds like you got that
started but um but so we're taking care
of
food lights and Water
Shelter Transportation how much is your
car payment so actually don't have a car
right now you don't have a car okay how
are you getting
around um where I'm living has a public
bus system that's free of charge okay
all
right and um so you're you and your soon
to be ex had one
car
so technically I have a car but it's in
Texas which doesn't help me okay um so
she's in Texas no she's here with it it
was a very sudden transition up
here uh due to the given
situation and so we I just kind of flew
up
here
uh okay where where why is your your you
were living in Texas before correct okay
so you just jetted out literally okay
correct and uh the car is parked where
at your family or with her my family on
my grandmother's property on your
grandmother's property you have a
relative that can bring you your
car it's honestly not worth bringing up
here it is it's more than
walking it would cost more than it's
worth in gas to bring up here so the car
is not worth
$400 so the problem is it only gets
eight miles per gallon it would cost
roughly $2,000 in fuel to drive it up
here and do you think that's what it's
worth I would even say it's worth that
okay so do you have a relative that will
take the car for you and sell it
today I can
biggest issue is trying to find a buyer
no it's not they can sell it today it's
a $2,000 car just go to the local
junkyard go to the tote toote lot and
sell it today you need money you are
broke you have a car sitting
there okay so what's happened is there's
so much freaking drama in your life that
your brain's not even functioning you're
you're you're got a lot of fog cuz these
are very clear things you should do
immediately you should sell this car
immediately you need to take the money
and find you a $2,000 car and buy one at
a garage sale in Seattle so that you're
not
walking and then immediately you need to
get two more extra
jobs and then immediately we're going to
start stacking up some cash and put some
buffer around you you are not on the
edge you are falling off the cliff we've
got to get you back up on top the lease
you signed Dwight for living is it is it
reasonable for what you're making right
now so it's 850 a month and it includes
utilities and internet okay that's great
yeah you can handle that on
5,000 yeah okay and your job is in
Seattle that makes
5,000 so I actually I don't actually
live in SE I live uh out on one of the
islands about two two and a half hours
from Seattle it's just the closest place
to me okay so the but but my point is
you you're making $5,000 working for the
Post Office
there yeah okay not in
Texas
hello uh yeah correct not in Texas okay
all right so what you've got to do is
break this down hun and a little bitty
baby steps about three or four right
things to do right now turn the car into
cash right now get some more jobs right
now delivering anything cutting dogs
hair walking dogs piling up dogs hair I
don't care what you do cut grass blow
leaves get you a leaf blower rich people
are afraid of leaves get you you know
put up Christmas trees I don't care but
right now you're going to start go make
some money because right now the reason
you you're traumatized and talking to
you your your verbal pattern says trauma
and so you're having trouble even
staying with me when we're talking
through these things so you have and and
that's all due to you having falling off
the edge of the cliff and you're
terrorized by your financial situation
and I don't blame you for that uh but
the way to fix it is to immediately
start stacking cash from any source that
you can that's legal and moral
immediately spending nothing but piling
it up piling it up piling it up and
let's take care of food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities yeah and
any expenses Dwight you can cut that we
just you get in the habit of just having
whether it's subscriptions memberships
like restaurant like whatever the thing
is like whatever you can cut finding
that margin is going to start to give
you peace even if it's 30 bucks here or
there at this point that's huge so like
go through and cut things exactly no car
payment $850 rent that includes
utilities dude you're making 5,000 plus
1,000 with Applebee's on the weekend
that's
$6,000 that's a $5,000 spread if you
don't blow that on the weekends doing
stupid butt stuff so you've got to T
tack this together and start stacking
some
cash
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a 5,00
,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
well we have had a bunch of new
wonderful things come out this fall Dr
John deloney about a month ago we
launched his uh second book it comes out
at number one his second number one
bestseller building a non- anxious life
yesterday we launched George camel's new
book Breaking Free from broke in
pre-sale the book will actually come out
in January on January 16th but um a
bazillion of you bought the book
yesterday thank you for that we
appreciate it uh the pre-sales help us a
bunch it helps George a bunch helps the
marketing and everything and uh this
coming
Tuesday
Rachel the mother of three of my
grandchildren is uh done a new
children's book her first children's
book I'm glad for what I have and uh it
is is a book about contentment obviously
yep and it is uh the illustrations are
world class because the illustrator that
we brought in is world class LA amazing
yep Lauren Lauren gyos gagos okay I know
I knew I was going to mess up the name
but yeah um but the book is um comes out
Tuesday and we've already sold thousands
and thousands of them in pre-sale just
some of you have heard about it on
Rachel's Instagram and so forth but the
uh you know the quality of these ill
illustrations and the quality of the
message for the little ones is I can't
get it open it's stiff it's brand new is
uh absolutely incredible and so uh just
to read to the uh the Bedtime Story age
yep uh and so we've got a bunch of those
in the Ramsey Clan right now so Papa
Dave and Mimi will be reading this uh
reading Rachel's own book to uh her own
kids and her cousins yes their Cous I
get I know I know if you're a I got two
of them tonight I got Charles tonight
and Eli tonight and then I just got a
text from Mom y'all are going to have
all of them I think wonderful seven
thanks
yay uh but yeah if you're a parent of of
kids I'm like it's just such a it's such
a weird time to be a parent especially
when you're like through the lens of
money you're trying to teach them about
money because everything's on your phone
you're buying things on Amazon things
just show up at the door uh you know I
mean even cards even debit cards like
aren't being used as much it's all just
Apple pay I mean like it's just it is
wild how transactions and seeing money
not being even exchanged right but
you're paying for stuff and your kids
don't see it and so it's like magic
things think if you're 5 years old stuff
just appears oh my three-year-old was
like let's we should just Amazon it Mom
and I was like oh oh gosh yep that's
like a thing now so I wanted them to
fully Embrace this idea and it's
something we talk about all the time is
that like it's okay to have stuff like
we can have toys and you can want things
but that excitement that you have with
that new toy it fades so quickly and so
if that is what you're depending your
joy and your happiness on it fades it
you're it has to come from somewhere
bigger and so teaching them that yeah
your stuff is not going to fulfill you
the way you think it does and so as a
parent um it's a it's a shorter book so
you're welcome parents and it Rhymes
it's it's just a sweet lesson in
contentment so I'm glad for what I have
that's right so pre-sale is you can buy
it now at Ramsey Solutions and we'll
ship them Tuesday that's what it amounts
to yes so uh they'll start they'll start
being on the shelves officially on
Tuesday and you'll find them wherever
great kids books are sold and certainly
Ramsey solutions.com in other news on
the other side of the spectrum mint is
shutting
down the uh best the largest budgeting
app our every dollar is the best
budgeting app by far it's uh but there's
about you know there's about four or
five people in this space uh of
budgeting apps that are of size were
certainly one of them with every dollar
mint has been the big dog for a while uh
into it uh owns it uh they bought a few
years ago Credit Karma and they've been
using mint as a feeder to Credit Karma
they were using using a free budgeting
tool with mint and they just wear you
out inside of mint to get you to take on
debt products and to worry about your
credit score with Credit Karma and
they're all always pedaling you credit
cards and everything else and apparently
they uh gave up on the budgeting thing
so mint is shutting down mint the
budgeting app owned by in is shutting
down in it announced on Tuesday that
mitt will get absorbed into in's other
Service Credit Karma when it officially
goes away on January the 1st it's not
clear whether Credit Karma will get the
budgeting features that mint is known
for actually it is clear because on a
support page on credit Karma's website
into it says the new experience in
Credit Karma does not offer the ability
to set monthly and category budgets
there we go so it's not Credit Karma has
got an experience but it's not a
budgeting experience so uh we invite all
of you that were on mint uh to come
check out every dollar it's free to
check it out and if you want the bank
connectivity there's a small fee to do
that uh for the uh further enhanced
experience with every dollar every
dollar is by far the most robust elegant
um budgeting app out there it was it's a
lot better than mint was was to say the
least but um mint is 100% free uh into
it also owns some of the connectivity
software that uh connects to Banks and
uh
so we actually used to when every do
first started we used to rent their
connectivity for our connectivity and we
moved off of their uh platform thank
goodness because now we' be screwed like
you people that are in mint you got all
your budgeting stuff in mint now so uh
you can come on over to every dollar we
welcome you and uh my goodness we're
excited to it's kind of a big deal in
the budget in our world some people may
be like okay but I'm like well they paid
they paid $170 million for this they
went into it bought it a few years ago
as a purely as a lead magnet it's there
just to draw customers into their debt
products like credit C my and into the
credit cards and so into it bought paid
almost $200 million for it and then um
gosh I don't know how many years ago
that was it's probably 10 or so years
ago but um um they should have called me
I would have bought it from them but oh
well not for 17 milon would have paid
them that wouldn't have paid them that
far but before you shut it down and get
nothing I'd give you something you know
and uh so but anyway y'all can come over
we though we got every dollar well I we
don't need it but I'd love to help all
those people yeah and so that's the
thing so yeah any of you that are there
spread the word uh that every dollar
still is the it's the only one of the
top budgeting apps that does have a free
feature that you can just jump into for
free so um uh I recommend the premium
it's much better CU When you connect to
your bank the transactions show up
automatically and you just drop them
into your budget it's much better it's
worth a few dollars to do that but uh we
have to pay for that service so you have
to pay us for that service that's how
that works so but it's such a um
especially for those of you listening
that are kind of newer to all of this
I'm telling you getting in the rhythm of
budgeting it gives you that level of
control cuz money can feel so out of
control if you don't have a plan if you
don't know what's going on and it just
feels like this like mystery when things
are just in your head I think they are
magnified the fear the disillusion all
of it and so having facts down and
seeing your numbers and just knowing
knowing what the month is knowing what
you're planning to do in food for
groceries and restaurants and you know
kids you know Christmas presents coming
up we have a we have a Christmas line
item in our budget for this month
because we're going to start buying
Christmas gifts I'm like there's just
something about having that and you guys
I mean I and I do literally open up
every dollar every single day and I'm a
free spirit spender so like I'm probably
the least likely to be the one that like
loves budgeting but every dollar has
just been in this Rhythm for me and you
track transactions you know what's going
on I'm like it's just it is the it's the
it's the first thing to get started like
if even if you're in a freakout Zone it
takes a lot of the freakout away I
almost wanted to tell Elliot that where
I'm like you'll know where your money's
going if you if do every dollar like do
a budget and it just gives you this
sense of control and it does make you
say no at times and we all hate that we
don't want it makes you know that you
should say no it doesn't say no that's
true that's true that's true you know
you are saying no to you because you
want to say yes to you later and that's
you're making a decision on purpose
instead of by chaos here's the weird
thing the opposite of good times are the
thing that is more stressful than bad
times is not knowing yes not knowing
where you are is much more anxiety
inducing than knowing where you are and
knowing in detail that it's bad and that
you can get out of it right even even if
it's bad knowing is less stressful then
I have no idea cuz the drama gets all
twisted up in your head and you do a
little drama queen dance between your
ears and blow everything out of
proportion and so but when you write it
down when you put it down you go okay I
got enough for food I got enough for
lights and water I I can pay the car
payment I can pay the rent and the the
mortgage oh so I'm only stressed about
these three things things not instead of
38 things yeah isn't that interesting
this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your PRI private student loan
debt with Y refi you'll have a payment
you can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi /
[Music]
Ramsey retel Cruz Ramsey personality
number one bestselling author my
daughter is my co-host today Cara is
with us in Newark New Jersey hi Cara how
are
you hi Dave and Rachel I'm doing well
thank you so much um sorry I'm just a
little bit nervous that's okay we've
never lost a patient what you got you're
good Cara so actually it's kind of funny
um I tried to get in last week to call
but um I just couldn't get through and I
just want to really Express gratitude to
the screener for letting me be on today
um it's the timing is very funny um
because
basically eight years ago my boyfriend
and I moved in together and I um ended
up accidentally getting pregnant and we
basically just reacted to
life we you know just everything that
came up and we you know reaction
reaction reaction Finance Finance uh
here we sit today and I'm I'm very
blessed we have you know um two very
healthy beautiful little girls and a
home but we also have a $100,000 of
various debts and a mortgage and
coincidentally we had been planning this
for a little bit but we're actually
going to town hall tonight to get our
marriage certificate and to move forward
as a legally married couple oh
congratulations well congrats that's
awesome thank you so much yeah no we we
we never like not planned on getting
married it just you know when
you've got you know two kids 18 months
apart it's you know like John you just
didn't plan on
anything yes I didn't plan and we you
know I have to say we ended up okay like
I said we're healthy we have a beautiful
home this and that but like we're ready
to do you know we've done things our way
yeah for so long and we're ready to do
things the right way I'm happy for you
congratulations how can we help you so I
guess my question was I'm a newer is
listener um and I just I understand the
Practical of okay yeah you go to the
bank you you you know you have a joint
bank account but I would just love to
hear your thoughts
on combining finances for the first time
as you know as a couple I know there's
probably a lot of people out there who
are like me yeah um who you know been
shacking up as you know you were saying
but uh you know what is your advice on
taking that step and combining finances
and moving forward yeah that way well I
think it's a great question because yeah
combining the finances happens when you
are legally married so just like what
you're doing is exactly right um just
from so many different stances um so I
think yeah the I mean the yeah the
logistics of it you know of getting a
joint bank account you guys combining
that uh budgeting together you know all
of that is is pretty you know in a sense
self-explanatory but I think the bigger
underlying picture of all of that is
knowing that you are on on the same team
with the value system around money and
so I think what happens with a lot of
couples is one feels like being that
they're being controlled by one spouse
one spouse goes and spends whatever they
want um one wants to go on vacation
while one wants to upgrade the car you
know so there's just all these different
things pulling at a couple and so as
much as you guys can be on the same page
with just your values and sitting down
and saying hey you know it could be
something as simple as like what are the
five things that we believe about money
what are the five principles we want to
live by what are the things that we want
to see as our family that we want goals
values like all of those kind of
conversations and you know and it can
look like hey we don't want to have debt
we you know maybe a goal is we're going
to get out of debt and a value is that
we're not going to use debt in our
family maybe it's that for these girls
you know we have a goal to maybe help
pay for their college when they're 18
and that's a goal we're going to shoot
for they want to model generosity before
them we want to be givers wants be
generous we want to be a generous family
yeah so combining it you know I think
the value system combining those
together uh is really important and then
also to know Cara you know and I know
you know this because you've been with
them for eight years but you know people
are opposites too so like forever and
ever amen my husband will always love
having four Excel sheets looking at all
different parts of our money all the
time and I don't want to look at those
you know even though I'm the one that
teaches about money every day I'm like I
don't want to but that will always be
him and that will always be me and
that's okay he's the nerd she's the free
yeah we're going to have different
interests in our involvement to the
detail of it but overall as our family
we see ourselves as one and we're moving
in the same direction from a value
standpoint and then the Tactical side
does play in that I think is important
that you guys yeah you you see
yourselves as one income that it's not
just his income your income that
together we are this family we are one
in that and you change your pronouns
change the pronouns sit down and do a
budget together we have $100,000 a day
we have a household income of X we are
doing this not his truck my truck now we
still call it his car my car at my house
because it's the one that Sharon drives
but we understand that we own those cars
and um I've actually owned a car that
she has not has never driven I've owned
it three years until the other night and
she finally drove the little sports car
home oh funny and I was scared to death
but yeah but she she drove it
I couldn't breathe still our car right
and so yeah you got to change your
pronouns and you're going to put the
whole thing our income into this account
we're going to take care of our bills
address our fears address our dreams and
make sure they're aligned with our
values what this forces you all to do is
to reconcile the differences in the way
you were brought up the differences in
the way you view the world one's a nerd
one's a free spirit one's a man one's a
woman they see things different
uh the differences in these things are
have to be reconciled it forces you to
do that so it forces you to deepen your
relationship when you combine your
accounts so it's an excellent question
given the uh momentous occasion that is
today for
you thank yeah I am I'm resonating with
all that I am definitely the the nerd I
guess you know yeah you made this phone
call you called the Ramsey Show on the
day you're getting married and you know
about money you're definitely the nerd
free spirit would have never called
today I love it that's awesome so great
I'm the nerd I would have done that I'm
planning out everything all the time
we're going to give you a wedding gift
we're going to give you financial piece
university and every dollar premium
together because you guys sit down and
go through these nine lessons together
uh join a class they're doing classes
Now by season of life so you guys can do
the Newlywed a bunch of newly WS in
there um but do that go through this CU
this that will give you guys a Common
Language too especially when you do
something together like that where
you're watching these videos you're
going through these exercises do that
together because that's a great
foundation and then every dollar premium
that's just it's amazing how old are
your
babies uh seven and five okay we're also
gonna send you Rachel brand new book I'm
glad for what I have for the 5-year-old
okay thank you so much you're the first
that's the first one of those we've ever
given I'm so glad yes what a great
wedding gift very cool thank you all
right you hang on uh we'll have Austin
pick up and since he was so nice to you
before now he's even going to be nicer
and give you a bunch of free stuff so um
congrats Cara and I just appreciate you
even asking that question and especially
giv your situation you guys have been
together for eight years you could have
legally had the document and kept living
as you did but you're feeling this shift
of what marriage does of oh my gosh
there's this level of unity that I want
and I want something different and you
guys you said you had like $100,000 in
debt and a mortgage and all of this
right so you're kind of at this cusp of
like okay this is a new season it's a
new it's a new life for you guys this is
one of those mile marker points that you
can put in your story and saying okay
this it no in November we got married we
started changing the way we're handling
money and that's going to trickle into
other parts of your life too Cara which
I'm excited about for you guys increase
communication one of the few things you
can find Total agreement on when
surveyed ladies that are married they
ask what would you like more and they
said
97% of the lady survey 97 that's all of
them so you know what they want more
communication to which the guy
said right and so um yeah but more
communication you want let me give you a
great communication tool where you
actually communicate feelings and you
actually communicate things that matter
and passions and dreams it's called a
budget it forces you to communicate
about every detail of your freaking life
and so it's it's a communication stuff
school stuff I mean oh yeah it all comes
out there where are we going for
Thanksgiving which parents house it's in
the budget it makes you makes you decide
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with with us netw week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel Cruz ramsy personality number one
bestselling author and my co-host today
Brett is in Providence Rhode Island hi
br welcome to the Ramy
show hi hi how can we
help um so I we are moving um and we're
selling the house and we're making a
profit on it and um recently I have been
seeing your show on like uh little clips
and I've been changing my mindset of
maybe you know having least Vehicles
isn't the best and smartest uh decision
I've ever made and uh
also though there's we have a plan to
use a good portion of the money uh from
selling the house to use that as a down
payment uh after a year of a sting
because we don't know the area we're
moving down to Orlando so we're trying
to get a you know it didn't feel right
fight unseen just to purchase a house
type thing so we're like we'll rent
there get a PE for the area you know
know where where we want to be
schoolwise that sounds
wise um so how much is how much you
going to get out of the house what's
going to be the cash in your hand I'm
guessing anywhere between 50 and 60,000
okay and what's it take to pay off your
cars um to pay off we wouldn't be able
to pay off both of them if uh so I have
you owe more than $60,000 on your
cars um well they're leases so I know
but they have a payoff they have an
early buyout provision if you call and
ask for the early buyout have you done
that
yet uh yeah so I know the early buyout
for my truck is
49 and uh the other vehicle is probably
around I would guess around like 40 or
so wow you're deep in some cars
dude
yeah uh what is the uh what's your
household
income um I do 180 a year okay all right
well A good rule of thumb if you want to
build wealth is to not have more than
half your annual income tied up in
things with motors and wheels you are
right on that
bubble okay um you're not over it but
you got a lot of car debt um and you
ain't got much home equity which is kind
of weird with income how long you've
been making that kind of
money um I've been making I I made 160
last year yeah um so you know a little
bit of bump um I've only been making
this money since like about I would say
2021 okay just a few years that makes
sense then okay and how old are you I
mean we bought this house I'm 35 okay I
bought this house with a VA loan so we
did no money down can tell yeah yeah
okay and uh purchased the house and in
two years somehow we're it um for a
profit which is just craziness but BR I
love I love Vehicles I'm a car nut um
mathematically uh as a financial person
I hate them because they're the largest
thing that we all buy that goes down in
value and they go down in value rapidly
and so you've got a lot of money tied up
in um things that go down in value uh
and so here's what I would do if I woke
up in your shoes um I would sell some of
these vehicles if not both one of them
if not both of them and move down in
vehicle to have less money tied up in
things going the wrong way so that I can
put more money into something that's
going up in value which is the purchase
of your home uh so I I would pay off one
and sell one and get you an inexpensive
car to drive and pile up cash during
this year for your down payment uh if I
if I were in your shoes uh if do you
have any money saved bread
um no um because obviously with moving
in expenses um our savings has been burn
burned paying for you know
transportation of one of the vehicles
because we're driving but we can't drive
both vehicles and you know paying for a
pod to transport yeah but all of that
but still you're making almost $200,000
a year and you had no money you just had
10 15,000 bucks to make the move was all
and you burned it so you've got to get
some money back in your hands cuz you
put it all into vehicles and so uh I
want you to make $175 $200,000 a year
and have some
money uh not be broke and and that's
what I if I were if that's what I would
like for you you know I love you I want
you to win and that's what I want for
you so if I were in your shoes as much
as I love a nice truck and I've got a
I've got a Ford Raptor that is an
absolute Beast it's amazing vehicle I
love cars um and and so but but I'm not
going to love them so much that they eat
me alive and they yours are eating you
up man because it's 90 grand and yeah
you got $90,000 tied up and your house
had nothing down and you barely had
enough cash to move and this and you
make a lot of money so I want you to
make a lot of money and have some and
and not be feeding these beasts so um
I'm probably selling the expensive one
paying off the in expensive one getting
a a a very inexpensive cash car down in
Orlando and so in Orlando you don't have
to even transport them yeah probably too
late they're probably already moved but
the uh but either way and just be be
free of all this because if you're
sitting there with no car payments and
you're renting you can stack some
serious cash for your down payment now
yep and um and then just draw a line in
the S says I pay cash for things from
now on yeah and don't be afraid to rent
for two years if you guys have to to cuz
you felt the pain of putting nothing
down and not having a lot of equity so
even if you guys kind of slow pace it
into that move that's okay too but if
you got no payments in the world and you
make 200 stack a
100 I mean live I mean oh darn I have to
live on 100,000 in Orlando I don't know
if I can do that or not of course you
can people do it every day so I mean
yeah stack a hundred in a year you know
uh and that's a pretty strong downstroke
for a house that'll put you in a good
place or wait two years and stack 200
yeah that'd be pretty neat this is the
kind of thing you can do when you're not
giving it all to the car company in the
form of a fleece so Brett you'd already
come to these conclusions but I probably
took you uh about four notches along the
radical steps uh you know took you a
little bit more radical than you wanted
to go when you called in be careful what
you wish for when you call the show boys
and girls but um that's what I would do
man just just cuz here's the thing for a
long time I drove cars I really hated
cuz they were crappy
and they were
hoopties and I drove like no one else so
that later I can drive anything I
freaking want
to you live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else a and so you you pay a price to win
you sacrifice to get yourself in a
position cuz making that kind of money
dude in five or six years you could be a
millionaire if you watch what you're
doing yeah absolutely okay so talk
through because we we always say and
it's been proven that Leasing is the
most expensive way to finance a vehicle
so talk through the lease aspect of it
just from like the the number standpoint
right of basically renting before you
have to buy it out when you finance a
vehicle the federal truth and lending
laws the regulations require them to
hand you a sheet that shows you what
your APR is the interest rate they're
ripping you off with okay when you lease
a vehicle you don't own
it so you're not technically B borrowing
money under the law so they do not have
to disclose the interest that they are
charging you but there is an interest
calculation because you can take the
actual cost of the car versus the stream
of payments called your lease payments
versus the the price at the closed in
lease at the back end these are three or
four Financial variables I can put them
in my financial calculator and back into
what your interest rate is it's called
the capitalization rate because it's not
Technic Al interest but as we've done
that in this industry now we found that
the typical car lease in America is
being capitalized at
14.2% so you're borrowing money at
subprime
rates when you lease a car but people
people that lease cars and I'm not
picking on Brett because he's come to
the conclusion that this doesn't work
but you know to answer your question F
this is not aimed at Brett this is just
talking about the subject right Brett
thank you for calling we appreciate you
when you lease a car you're asking what
the interest rate is you're the people
that ask how much down and how much a
month what's the least amount per month
and the least amount down and I can
drive this
car rich people ask how much poor people
and broke people ask how much down and
how much a month and that's what drives
you into the lease the lease is the most
expensive thing on the car lot that's
why the car companies push them so hard
because they make more money on those
than they do on the stinking
car that's it it's math this is the
Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships open phones at
88255 225 Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality
number number one bestselling author
multiple times and co-host of the smart
money happy hour on the Ramsey Network's
podcast with George camel she's my
co-host today and my daughter open
phones atle
88255 225 Heather starts this hour in
Tampa Florida hi Heather how are
you well I'm better than I deserve good
for you I love it how can we
out yes um so I'm just trying to come up
with a good investment plan um both my
husband and I we've been married now 20
years this month and um I'm always just
trying to look for better opportunities
to try to keep um you know uh investment
up and while we still kind of work you
know job to job we kind of work paycheck
to paycheck and so um I have a Apple
stock that I invested in many years ago
and I have a good wealth since we've
been in Apple stock we've tripled since
we started and um we also have two
rothar Ira each just only 6,000 for him
8,000 for me and um we got about $20,000
in savings and so I was trying to figure
out I also do have just um a house that
we just bought um and so we're paying on
that and two cars is what we have uh no
other debts just those things and so I
was trying to figure out in my mind what
I could do with my savings instead of
making it so unproductive just sitting
in the account you know I have only
$20,000 in savings but would it be best
to pay off a car would it be best um to
uh cash out the Apple stock because you
know of concerns they always say around
election time specifically with crash
they always talk about that happening so
I'm just trying to get a better idea
because I spoke with my financial
advisor and he suggested maybe money
market funds and I'm not very wise as
far as
financially okay um money market funds
for the
20,000 yeah he wasn't saying the full
20,000 he was like you could start out
putting 10,000 in money market funds
which like I said I'm not very familiar
with it yeah well money market fund is a
fancy savings account it doesn't pay
much pays more than a bad savings
account at a bank it's basically a high
yield savings account it's what it is so
um but still not paying big money now
here's the thing what we teach Heather
is that your most powerful wealth
building tool is your
income okay your income right now is
going to two car payments if you had
those car payments going into
Investments every month you would be
Building Wealth pretty rapidly mhm so
our first goal is going to be clear
those car payments what do you owe on
your
cars so um it's about uh 16,000 and
18,000 wow okay and you've only got 20
what's your household income right uh my
household incomes about a little over a
100,000 good okay a year all right so if
I woke up in your shoes we teach a
process to get you to wealth by getting
you out of debt called the baby steps
baby step one is $11,000 in the bank now
how much do you have an Apple stock what
is it valued at today if you cash it
in 21,000 excellent okay all right this
is going to jar your system can you hold
on to your chair for a second because
I'm getting ready to knock you out of
the
chair okay here we go you ready for the
ride Ready set go here we go you ready
oh my just be be kind I'm going to be
kind but it's going to scare the crap
out of you are you ready I'm cashing in
the Apple stock and the 20,000 and
paying off my cars
today mhm
wow can you
breathe well of course I mean now that
would be stupid if you don't do the next
thing and the next thing is your first
thing you got to do now is rebuild your
emergency fund which is what that 20,000
is it's not supposed to make any money
it's supposed to sit there and keep life
off of your head cuz life's going to
come and land on your head and you won't
eat a helmet and that's what the ,000
bucks is it's the umbrella in the rain
cuz some days it rains so you need a
rainy day fund that's your 20,000 it's
not supposed to be making you a bunch of
money but right now we're paying off a
car with us so it doesn't matter so the
cars are gone any money that we don't
have in a retirement account you and
you'll have 7,000 left after that
yeah start your emergency F start your
emergency fund I do want to set that
over in a money market or a high yield
and I want you to get about 20,000 back
in there that's your three to six months
of expenses that's baby step three now
you don't have any payments and you've
got that so now we've got to start
investing which is 15% of your income
that'd be
$155,000 a year 1,00 bucks a month going
in your company 401ks with a match in
good mutual funds or sit down with your
broker or get a new one and sit down and
get your uh your Roth IRA going into
good mutual funds and be easy Heather
because there's no car payment to to
your point earlier yep then you freed up
so much income do you know
month-to-month Heather and so those Roth
IRAs that have six in one and eight in
the other you're going to start seeing
lots of traction in that and it's yeah
you start adding $1,000 $1,500 a month
to your retirement plan that's $15
$118,000 a year making a 100 Grand then
um and if you got a match at work and
these mutual funds go up this year it
would have made a little over 10% this
year year to date if you put it in
January 1 to right now you would have
made 10% on good mutual funds and
whoever's talking to you about a stock
market crash quit listening to those
fools okay stock market's not going to
crash it goes up and it goes down goes
up and it goes down election time it is
always crazy there's always been stupid
people in Washington of both Brands and
there's still stupid people in
Washington of both Brands some right now
some of them are more stupid than normal
but there're stupid people in Washington
okay so that's never that's not a new
that's not new information no but to her
Point election time people do like
things do kind of stall out people hold
they watch they see the stock market
doesn't crash on Election it doesn't no
it doesn't crash but you're going to see
a little bit of that volatility and
that's normal you can go back to
basically every election year every four
years and you see the same thing so it
doesn't mean it's going to crash but
yeah goes up it goes down and you're in
the right you're in the right of it all
so you just right you just dumping 1100
bucks 1,00 bucks a month 1,400 bucks a
month every single month automatically
out of your check into your 401K with a
match or into Roth IRAs and Heather and
I think Heather you're you're a prime
example that so many people experience
with their money honestly you're trying
to do like five different things you got
a single stock here you're trying to do
some retirement you got car payments you
have a little bit of money here savings
and it's like I you feel so scattered
versus clearing it all out and saying
boom boom boom boom boom and then you
can now tomorrow or after the emergency
fund is fully funded after that 7,000
you can fully focus on retirement you
have one thing to do at a time and
that's what gives you power and less of
this like bizarre feeling that you
probably feel with your money yeah if
you pay off the cars and have 7,000 left
over today by by the end of the year
you'll have your 20,000 and in January
you'll start saving 15% from this point
forward of your income going into
retirement you'll retire wealthy if
you'll do those things but you got to be
on a budget to do it you got to be in
agreement with your husband and no more
borrowing on stupid cars stop it this is
the ramse
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their one 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
well a lot of happening things around
the Ramsey organization these days the
ramsy Cash Christmas Cash giveaway has
started you can win one of our
$500 weekly prizes between now and
Christmas every single week Andor the
grand prize of
$5,000 giving away the week of Christmas
all you got to do is enter and you can
enter up to once a day every day at
ramseys solutions.com giveaway you can
also check out the great gift ideas at
the uh Ramsey store at ramseys
solutions.com we've got a the $12 sale
is going and that's all the uh number
one bestselling books that we have had
out over the past years like The Total
Money Makeover own your past change your
Future Baby Steps millionaires know
yourself know your money Rachel's number
one uh last number one anyway and uh all
the book we did that was a number one
together smart kids smart money smart
kids that was her first number one uh
and man those books all of those books
every book I've done is in there $112
the questions for humans cards with Dr
John deloney the Christmas edition is
back those are $10 all kinds of fun
gifts and lots of new things there on
the website Dr John delon's uh brand new
number one bestseller building a
non-anxious life is on there uh you can
get George's new book pre-sale Breaking
Free from broke and uh launching next
Tuesday Rachel's brand new children's
book I'm glad for what I have great
Christmas gift especially for the the
5-year-old what is six years old and
down probably yeah and honestly the
message is great for parent for the
adults too so you adults get this and
read it over and over to yourself and
get some contentment I I need the
message so I wrote it I was like it's
all good for us to
remember it's all good I'm glad for what
I have the brand new children's book by
Rachel Cruz comes out Tuesday so it's in
the store for Christmas as well it's all
there and free money you just can't beat
it go to ramsy solutions.com
giveaway to register for the free money
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighbor your hub for Home
Services with 19 service Brands
Nationwide and today's question
neighborly I'm sorry neighborly network
of local providers has trusted service
professionals to handle multiple
different services in and around your
home visit neighbor.com Ramsey to find
and schedule a service today and today's
question comes from Warren in Washington
DC I have a large amount of debt
wouldn't it be better to file for
bankruptcy to have a fresh start and
then build wealth instead of taking
years to pay off debt and then start to
build wealth when is bankruptcy a good
option uh we would say in the very very
very rare case is bankruptcy an option
uh because most of the time it is a u
and bankruptcy doesn't solve a u problem
it may wipe debts away not your student
loans and then it's on your record for a
while uh but the problem is usually when
it comes to money it's us it's the
person handling it and so while in one
sense it could sound like an easy um
exchange I'll take bankruptcy for the no
debts it doesn't change the pattern of
what caused you to get in there in the
first place and and most time we find
people can get out of debt I mean rare I
don't I mean it's only been a handful of
times on this show that you've ever even
uh entertain the idea of giving someone
advice for bankruptcy yeah I I I don't
tell people to file bankruptcy and I
don't tell people to file
divorce um with the exception of uh a
situation where the wife is a punching
bag because her husband's scum in that
case file divorce get out of there he's
scum uh but other than that I don't tell
people to do the stuff like this I don't
make decisions like that for you on this
show I will tell you that you should
file bankruptcy about as often as you
should file for a divorce which is
almost never if you have a big fight
with your wife you don't go file for
divorce it's a we've been through a
rough patch this this summer you don't
go file for a divorce you work it out
you sit down with a marriage counselor
you sit down with your pastor you read a
marriage book or six um and you work
work on it and you learn how to do it
and you fix it and the same thing's true
with your money now that's from a guy
that did file bankruptcy but we fought
two and a half
years to keep from filing bankruptcy
they were down to we've been sued 78
times before we filed bankruptcy they
were coming to take the furniture out of
our house and Rachel was two months
old and I decided they're not taking the
baby bed I fought this for two and a
half years I've sold everything we owned
I've done everything we could do took it
all the way to the B them and then we
filed for bankruptcy in September of
1988 and uh that's what started this
whole Ramsey Movement by the way was my
stupidity so uh and I fought it all the
way to the bottom I I now know things
that I didn't know then that I could
have done further there's some
techniques I could have used some dance
steps dance moves I could have used to
uh to delay it even further and I might
have made it through if if I'm knowing
what I know now but um but I didn't know
I was out of gas and yours was all real
estate not beat out yeah it was all real
estate it wasn't consumer but I didn't
have any Consumer Debt hardly at all um
I borrowed on the cars to buy houses so
I didn't have car payments but I had car
payments but um so but anyway all all
that aside you're uh uh Warren you're
not
bankrupt your bankruptcy is not a
technique for Building
Wealth it's like life insurance is not a
technique for building an
estate you don't buy life insurance to
leave your children something because
that doesn't work it leaves the
insurance company stuff is what I does
so no you're you're not bankrupt you
need to take the years to pay off the
debt as a matter of fact you need to
take months instead of years because you
get six jobs and um the person that you
become Warren while you fight your way
through this is much more important than
any mathematical equation that you're
looking at mhm the toughness and the
perseverance that will be required of
you to work your way through this is
going to make you into the man that will
be able to build and manage wealth in
the next chapter of your
life but this is not a I'm just going to
dust this off get out free jail card not
it's not you know that's childish and no
you don't use bankruptcy that way and by
the way the way the bankruptcy laws are
written right now if you've got a big
income and this debts just an
inconvenience to you and you go in you
think you're going to file bankruptcy
and wipe out the stuff the the
bankruptcy laws are written now where
they're going to take you out of that
chapter 7 and put you in a Chapter 13
and make you pay
payments a Chapter 13 is a payment
bankruptcy lasts 5 years 60 months there
are formulas that the law has in place
the regulations have in place that force
you to do that there's mathematical
tests and it forces you into paying
payments and so if you have have the
ability to pay payments and just don't
want to um the law doesn't allow you to
do that anymore it's going to smack you
upside the head and make you pay
payments anyway in bankruptcy so then
you got double dump you got payments and
you got bankruptcy so you got absolutely
no traction you got none of your little
idea worked so no you're not bankrupt
yes you need to roll up your sleeves and
fight through this yes you need to sell
so much stuff that kids think they're
next yes you need to work all the time
yes you need to get the scissors out and
place them across the credit cards and
press hard repeatedly it's called
plastic surgery you need to get out of
the debt business you've got to learn
what caused you to get here and then
fight your way through it's what
happened to us afterwards afterwards we
had to start over and we had to learn
what happened so that I'm never back
there
again and I'm just going to start fresh
it's not going to work dude the law is
not going to let you and uh and you're
going to miss out on who Warren would
have become well yeah cuz you don't
change
and that that's why we even are cautious
when people get a lump sum of money
whether from like an insurance
settlement or um you know um from uh
what is it when when someone passes an
estate no in Insurance life insurance
insurance inheritance that's what I was
thinking of inheritance but when people
call and they have a sum of money and
they're like I can go and pay off my
debt we're like okay that's great
because yes we want you debt free and
you can use it but also you have to just
be careful in that when there's a sweep
of something that happens that comes
through again you're not changing who
you are and you're the one that got
yourself in this position and so the
beauty of the sacrifice through all of
that is you change with it so on the
other end you feel the pain that you've
walked through versus having one big
sweep that just kind of takes care of
everything so that's always even the
word of caution with yeah if you're
getting an insurance settlement or an
inheritance or something like that just
to be cautious that it's still you
handling that money and if you haven't
changed your money situation might not
change either either yeah I'll go a step
further if you can pay your bills and
you just refuse to that's
stealing a stealing it's
unethical this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states
so see if chm could be right for your
family check out more today at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget
retel Cruz Ramsey personality number one
bestselling author is my co-host today
in the lobby of ramsy Solutions on the
Dead free stage Nicholas is with us hi
Nicholas how are you great how are you
Dave better than I deserve welcome where
do you live York Pennsylvania which is a
small town outside of the capital of
Harrisburg absolutely welcome to
Nashville it's a bit of a hall down here
just a little bit good to have you so
how much debt have you paid
$56,700
32 way to go how long did that take 25
months all right and your range of
income during that two years started at
56,000 and end this year at about 80 wow
good for you what do you do for a living
I'm in retail management and I have a
small business that I run as well cool
what's your business we uh we sell seat
inserts for race car drivers it helps
reduce the risk of spinal injury when
there's a crack yeah wow that's awesome
good for you what kind of debt was the
57,000
44,000 student loans and then 12,000
business loan okay all right good for
you how old are you 24 and no payments
in the world that's amazing good for you
absolutely amazing so tell us the story
how did all this happen and how did you
get connected to Ramsey and decide to be
a weird 24y old with no debt so I was in
college and I was a huge personal
finance nerd so I was watching a lot of
content and I know Dave you have a very
thick skin I'm sure after 30 years but I
was like these people are bashing this
Dave Ramsey guy maybe I maybe I should
check it out so I think it's important
to listen to other perspectives and I
really appreciated how you guys uh
spread the message of helping others who
are struggling and and devise a plan for
for those who are in need and and
especially in debt so Flash Forward uh
shortly after graduation not making the
uh the smartest decisions I had $50 in
my bank account and I was at the casino
and uh last $400 I had and that was my o
crap moment you know time to get serious
and time to really buckle down and and
follow the plan so that's what uh that's
where it all started so it turns out the
casino is not a wealth building method
it is
not you know the fun thing about some of
those haters in our space um is I I've
met many of them over the years and they
don't really hate me I'm just really
good clickbait yes you know so if you
put Dave Ramsey in the title of your
thing it just shows up everywhere it's
just really good for your thing so the
reason they hate on me is it helps them
you know that's why that's why a lot of
them do it they don't even really
disagree they just it's just easier to
disagree than it is because they don't
get any lift if they agree so it doesn't
help their social media presence so
anyway all right cool so 57,000 is paid
off you got connected to us cuz we were
the weird ones in the space now you're
the weird one in the space cuz you're
debt-free most 24y old are walking
around going I don't know what I'm going
to do and you actually had a clue man
congratulations thank you yeah I mean
and you look at your income and what you
paid off I'm like you you did a lot you
did a lot of just sacrifice so what
would you say to 24 year olds out there
that are like oh we just want to enjoy
life and just move at the speed of
whatever we want like you cuz you were I
mean you were on plan yeah yes so I
think it comes down to three things um
sacrifice work ethic and vision so I
went to a state school just happened to
be one of the more expensive ones in
Pennsylvania and um so from there uh got
a good degree got a good job but you
know that's not always enough and uh
wish I would have found you guys earlier
in my College college Years but um so
that's kind of where the work ethic
comes in and really just long hours long
days sometimes 12 14 straight days I was
up so early sometimes uh in my hometown
the lights weren't even working it was
the blinking yellow you know not even
not even uh the red light uh yellow
green so but I think work ethic and then
Vision you know Dave we had this
conversation in my head like 56 times
already so uh that was the vision that
that helped me get here today so good
how does it feel oh it's incredible the
good news about going on The Road Less
Traveled is there's no traffic and that
includes 6 o'clock in the morning 5:00
in the morning yeah with a blinking
yellow light yeah that's there there's
nobody there cuz nobody's willing to pay
that price mhm that's why there's nobody
out there so you know if I get out where
there's a whole bunch of people I'm
worried cuz that means I'm in the wrong
place cuz they're all on the wrong place
I know they are so good for you man
congratulations thank you what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is I think it's um I think it's
sacrifice uh work ethic and vision those
three things that combination and um you
know making sacrifices you know not
buying the first car and things like
that that go a long way you you know um
you know everyone's on their own Journey
but you know it it's freeing to know
that there's no more payments or oh yeah
what do people in your life say as you
were in this journey were you pretty
vocal about it or did you kind of just
buckle down yourself did you get your
own haters uh you know you you need your
own haters man um people are very
supportive I have a very good crew here
today and I'm I'm very appreciative and
grateful that we were able to make the
trip down so uh you know I think there's
always haters I'm sure you guys know
that and um but a lot of lot of support
good good so is this family and friends
or just friends or yes so my parents my
grandmother my cousin and his wife and
two friends all right very good that's
that's perfect that's good that's a good
support group cuz it is tough to do this
by yourself you can do it but it's tough
and uh cuz you got to stand up cuz
people think you're weird because you
are weird normal's broke you know
normal's lazy normal's out of control
normal's chaotic uh all that what are
you going to do now you're four no
payments you'll get your emergency fund
in place I'm assuming and then beyond
that what's your what do you want to do
baby step 3B right now saving for the
down payment and then looking to do some
travel so obviously we're going to enjoy
our Nashville weekend here yay and uh
some International destinations in in
the new year which I'm looking forward
to where you going do know uh Europe for
a week with my buddy Tom and fun yeah
we're going to Barcelona and London both
good stops you spent some time in barcel
didn't you no no I was outside of Madrid
outside of Madrid in college yeah she
did she did a little uh study abroad
thing back in the day which means I'm on
vacation and we're paying tuition that's
what that means but yeah sort of it was
great it was great yeah way to go man
congratulations congratulations H well
done hey we've got uh the live and give
box for you it's got the baby steps
millionaires book cuz that's definitely
where you're going my man 24 years old
and already rocking it Well Done amazing
and The Total Money Makeover book to
give away to one of those friends who
wasn't sure you were crazy you'll prove
it now and of course the uh Financial
Peace University membership if you
haven't been through it go through it if
you have or don't want to give it to
somebody it's live and give that's what
the box is for people buy it all the
time to do that they take some of it and
use it they um give away part of it and
so we're going to give it to you to say
thanks for being here so proud of you
hero thank you well done man great well
done got to feel studly yes thank you
very much good stuff man very cool a lot
of hard work absolutely yeah the
blinking yellow light man that's a thing
that's when you know you've been getting
it that that's good I like that a lot
I've been there a lot most of my life so
very very cool good for you all right
it's Nicholas York Pennsylvania $
57,000 paid off in 25 months making 56
to 80 count it down let's hear a debt
free screen 3 2 1 I'm deck
free yeah
yeah
woohoo I love
it so great Rachel I've been saying for
years that uh while people uh in my
Boomer AG group have been trashing the
Gen Z and trashing the Millennials yes
uh that there are ones worthy of being
trashed but we also run into the good
ones oh yeah and we run into them on
this debt-free stage quite often these
days from 24 to 34 years old
some of them in 34 paying off their home
and that kind of stuff and uh there for
those of you out there you just got to
know we've got two really good
Generations now the media paints them
with a wide brush and somebody lives in
their mother's basement or some kind of
crap and that's just not true I mean you
got a 24 year- old with a blinking
yellow light cuz he's up so stinking
early in the morning busting it getting
it paying off
$57,000 worth of student loans he's not
sitting around whing
sucking his thumb waiting on Joe Biden
to fix his life he did it that's a gen Z
right there and there's a bunch of them
there's a whole bunch like out there
it's not all dead beats they're not all
off you know this these are two really
good Generations I got a bunch of them
working here they're good innovated
smart hardworking Mission driven there
we go Nicholas That's it man way to go
man you're an absolute hero this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality my
co-host today this is the ramsy show
where we talk about your life and your
money open phones atle 8825 5225 Jay's
in Kansas City hi Jay how are you I am
blessed how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up well before I start I
want to thank you for your foundations
curriculum for high schoolers and
homeschoolers because without that I
wouldn't be debt free today wow wow very
cool were were you a student in it or a
teacher or I I took it as a homeschooled
student uh years and years and years ago
wow that's for you Jay so my question
today is I'm baby step four five and six
I have about 120,000 Saed for retirement
that's across my IRA my Roth IRA my
wife's Roth IRA and the 401K how old are
you and I uh 30 years old good for you
well done thank you I feel from what
I've been running the numbers with that
I'm on the teetering edge of coasting
Financial Independence and I'm trying to
best understand my plan with the end in
mind so how I'm going to turn that Nest
Egg when I retire into income I found on
your
website a little article that talks
about a four to 5% withdrawal rate and I
was trying to run the numbers around
that and I thought I was close and then
about what was it a month ago George
camel released a video that said that
the withdrawal rate for a 30-year time
Horizon should be closer to
3% so if I can establish Financial
Independence comfortably then I was
wondering if I could ease up on baby
step four to pay off the house faster
okay I'm a little confused because I
don't know what the hell George is doing
doing a 3% withdrawal rate because
that's absolutely wrong I don't I'm
going to have to find out where that
video is and get it taken down um cuz
that's just wrong you don't need to have
a 3% withdrawal rate that's
ridiculous um or I hope you
misunderstood I hope we didn't put out
trash like that four to 5% like that no
it shouldn't be four to 5% it ought to
be more than that I mean if you're
making 12
in good mutual funds and the S&P is
averaged 11.8 and if inflation for the
last 80 years is averaged 4% if you make
12 and you need to leave 4% in there for
inflation raises that leaves you
eight so I'm perfectly comfortable
drawing eight but if you want to be a
little bit conservative seven but sure
not five or
three well I was trying to back check it
because you know three to five I thought
that was a range and a lot of the
studies I found show there's a lot of
studies that are stupid in this
space just wrong listen man the math I
just gave you is the math if you're
making
12% and inflation is four and you leave
four in there so your nest egg Grows by
four it's simple eight is what's left
over so if you got a million dollars and
you leave 4% in there that's 40,000
bucks okay so you're now you have milon
40 so the next year you get you're you
get a rate of return of 12% 11 a half%
on the million
40 and the next year it'll be you know a
million 90 1.1 right and because so your
nest egg is growing by the rate of
inflation giving you a cost of living
raise every year so as long as you're
doing that you're fine uh and so if you
want to be a little bit conservative
maybe 5% but there's all these goobers
out there have always put this 4% crap
in the market and I'm just IR rate right
now that we have joined the stupidity
why is it that stupid though I just it's
too low it's too low because it's not
realistic you do not need to live on 4%
of your money for your nest egg to
survive yeah even if you did a rate of
return of 10% or something and what it
sets up is this guy now he he doesn't he
doesn't think he's got enough money and
he's already got $120,000 and he's 30
years old he's on a plan he's on a plan
to be very wealthy and he's worried he's
going to have enough money or not yeah
you know because because we people
stupid people put out low withdrawal
rates like you listen if you if you if
you think you can only pull off 4% off
of Investments making 12 where the flip
is the other 8% going well 4% of it went
to inflation that's where it went the
other 4% is just sitting there so you
are growing your Investments instead of
living off of them I'm not destroying
the nest egg I'm not even touching the
nest egg I'm growing The Nest Egg by
leaving 4% in there taking eight off of
a 12 so go go a 10% rate of return go a
little bit more conservative with your
rate of return go 10% what would you do
with 10% well then four off of that so
six six yeah but I why why are you going
to
underinvested date was 10% is 10% and
we're not even at the end of the year
yet yeah you know and and and and
everybody's talking about how bad the
economy is so you know I most years mine
have done much better than 12 and so I'm
but wouldn't you but if you can do your
standard of living though lower than
what you need like if you don't need if
you don't need it that's fine yeah like
I'm 62 I'm pulling or 63 I'm pulling
nothing off of mine right cuz I don't
need it I still work I still have an
income right right I I don't need any of
it so it's all just sitting there could
do% the problem is is when you go down
these stupid nerd rabbit holes in these
Reddit threads with these morons who
live in their mother's basement with a
calculator and then you then you put
that out into the dadgum community and
then people go I don't have enough money
it's hopeless I'll never be able to save
enough to retire a million dollars
should create for you an $80,000 income
boys and girls so you
perpetually like if
forever you should be able to pull
80,000
forever and never destroy it now that
that and so when you tell people that a
million dollars creates a $440,000
income you go oh I've got to have $2
million and I can't make that then this
system doesn't work so what you're doing
with this bogus math is you're stealing
people's hope that's why I'm pissed
about it because it's hope stealing with
super nerds that have never really done
anything to start with they don't have
any Investments they just have theories
I've actually freaking got Investments
my money is actually invested exactly
the way I teach people to invest it and
I'm easily making 12% of my money easily
you know average throughout a decade so
it's just asinine that we do this stuff
so no honey you need to save 15% of your
income in baby step 4 you get your house
paid off when your house gets paid off
you will increase your investing ratios
above that you are not going to retire
poor stay away from 4% withdrawal rate
morons who are telling you this is the
thing so God it's just aggravating so I
yeah I can see the Hope because because
it makes people think they need $2
million when they only need a million
doar or it makes them think they need $8
million when they only need $4 million
yeah and here's the way the end of the
story is this no one ever actually ends
up ever with what you thought you were
going to end up with right ever
So you you're sitting there at 30 or 29
years old and you're doing these
projections which it's okay to do the
projection sure and you project out
there and you go okay I'm going to have
$1.7 million at this current rate yeah
but you know what you haven't factored
in is between now and 35 years from now
when you're 65 you're going to run into
flying monkeys wicked witches have you
seen The Wizard of Oz you're going to be
on the yellow brick road sometimes and
and and sometimes you're going to have
money drop in your hands out of nowhere
you're going to make more money than you
ever need you're going to have ruby red
slippers sometimes and sometimes you're
going to have flying monkey Steel in
them and at the end of the story you're
not your little projection is not
accurate you're going to make a b
usually most people end up with about 2x
of what they thought they were going to
end up with if they stay on their plan
right right because they're PL because
you never you know like here here here's
another thing here's what happens
between 30 and 65 your income goes
up almost every freaking year your
income goes up I mean you think about
what people made 40 years ago as an
average income when I started this show
30 years ago the average household
income in America was 40 you know what
it is now
73 that's
average and so if you're just average
your income's going to double
and if you're actually doing these nerd
calculations you're already above
average so oh my God it's going to be
okay it's going to be okay and I tell
you the the financial industry and their
moronic paralysis of the analysis pisses
me off to no end this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
n
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality
is my co-host today number one
bestselling author and my daughter open
phones here atle
88255 22 25 filipo is with us to start
this hour in Los Angeles Hi filipo how
are
you Hi great how are you guys better
than we deserve what's
up uh so uh I'm working my way um we
actually my wife and I are working our
way through the B steps um I got your
book that to Money Makeover I'm reading
through that um we had the a nice
emergency fund for now it's about $3,000
in it and um I'm trying to plan out the
debt repayment because we have uh two
cart loans that amount are about 50,000
total and I have an hel loock uh on our
house and it has about 125,000 in it um
so you a debt on the HELOC or an amount
that is not used on the HELOC no no the
debt on the helck you owe 20,000 on your
helck correct
okay uh 50,000 on your cars what do you
make uh total about between 140 and 160
a year okay all right and and you have
$3,000 right
now in the emergency fund yes yeah okay
all right and your question's what uh uh
so I want to sell both cars because I
can probably get um what we owe uh back
MH and I'm wondering if I should use the
HELOC to pay for a much lower payment
car um and so to consolidate all that in
one or to get another another way
smaller
loan to get a car because we can get
another car from my sister-in-law that
my wife can use and then we will need a
family car cuz we have an 11mon old
MH okay so you're going to sell the two
the cars you owe 50 ,000 on they'll
bring 50 and then you've got you're
going to get a car from your
sister-in-law and then you got to get
another car on payments but it'll be
less than
50 oh yeah I was thinking about between
15 and 20 okay all right somewhere in
that range so the neither one of your
car current cars are uh 15 or
20 no there one is 23 the other one is
24 okay well moving from 23 to 15 is not
that big a deal when you make one
60 so I'd probably just keep keep one of
those sell the other one and take your
sister-in-law's car and call it a day
and let's get it then let's get it paid
off as fast as
possible right right right yeah that's
that's the plan yeah which one of those
you want to
keep uh the trucks because it's it's
bigger and you know for the baby and the
if we have to move
stuff so it's got a it's crew cab it's
got a second Cab in it our second row
seat it's a Super Crew so yeah you can
it's basically a four-door car okay I
got you yeah yeah exactly and it's good
for travel too okay yeah that's fine
keep keep one of them and then let's get
the other one paid off as soon as
possible if that's your only dead except
your
home yeah I mean the car and then the
helck that I want to you know it's it's
it's burdening on me it's like $1,000 a
month payments yeah we tell folks on the
on helocs they go in baby step six if
they're more than half your annual
income which they are in your case yeah
so I'm going to roll it over to six
what's your uh mortgage balance on your
first
mortgage uh 525 what's your interest
rate on
that uh
3.2 what's the interest rate on the
helck well we started at six and now
it's about nine yeah the
last this is why we tell people not to
do these all the time okay um yeah I'm
with you I I normally I would lean into
it in baby step two because it's uh I
mean in six because it's more than half
your annual income but uh once you get
rid of the car debt I probably would
reach over and start smacking it because
it's such a high interest rate exactly I
think I can once I get rid of the car
payments I can start throwing like you
know somewhere between three and 4,000 a
month at it yeah yeah I think that's
probably wise I'm with you on that let's
do that but yeah I would keep the truck
and pay it off and sell the other one
and take the law car for the second car
and uh that puts you in a really good
place you're making good moves there mhm
for sure when I think you know it's so
interesting with the HELOC discussion
because even talking to people that we
know in our lives are like oh it's it's
such an easy route to feel like you get
what you want when you want it kind of
thing especially with your house if
you're going to go do Renovations all of
it it's it is the one piece of debt that
I'm starting to hear people justifying
oh they've always Justified everything
but the
the it it's the thing is it's a sleeper
because it sounds like oh well this is
no big deal it's actually it's actually
a piece of crap as far as debt goes it's
a really horrible product and here's the
reason you put your home at risk to go
on vacation I mean how stupid is that
well I know a lot put your home at risk
to buy a couch or to do Renovations or
to do a renovation you know instead of
cash flowing the renovations and it was
just it was just immaturity I want it
and I want it now and I'm four freaking
years old that's all it is and then but
I but I I've got it on a HELOC and that
makes it sound sophisticated you're not
sophisticated stupid and so are they
always veritable rates and that's the
other problem they they have calls in
them they'll re you re-qualify you you
lose your job and that thing comes up
with a call they'll Fork close on your
butt yeah so or they'll have a
three-year balloon on them or and
they've got a stinking variable rate and
variable rates were great for the decade
that we sat around at 3% you didn't
worry about a variable rate but now you
guys are facing reality out there
variable rate means variable and it
usually means up when it comes to a bank
right so here we go now you get screwed
now you got a
9% second mortgage on your house oh my
bless his heart I mean I'm glad he's I'm
glad he's upset about it yeah oh yeah
yeah but yeah it's the problem though is
what you're saying is true it's just it
it's well and I think it's season
everybody acts like it's okay and it's a
horrible product and it's so interesting
when you go through life and you look
from 18 to 65 and you start to watch
these
Financial products really play a bigger
role in your season of life so if you
are if you've been married you have kids
you're kind of in that seasonal life of
like the 30s 40s that's when the helck
right it's not as much the student loan
anymore you're trying to pay it off the
student loan was the in your 20s then it
moves to uh well you move into and all
along you've been over spending on
credit cards so now we're going to move
those over onto the he and we're going
to keep spending like we're in Congress
you watch it and then you get to the you
know your your age group and it's
reverse reverse mortgages and all this
stuff so I'm like you just have to be
aware your season of Life they they know
how to how to how to pick at the places
that you're discontent in thinking I can
get ahead in this and need blog about
stupid things at each decade of your
life yeah the 20s the 20s stupid things
the 30s stupid things the 40s stupid
things the 50s stupid things the 60s and
70s stupid things yeah they're stupid
things we can tell how old you are by
the stupid things you're doing this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
I'm Dave Ramsey your host Rachel Cruz is
my co-host today open phones at8
5225 if you like what you hear help us
out we need your help subscribe to the
show click the Subscribe button click
the follow button share the show clip a
link out and click a cut a link out and
send it to your friends or click the
share button anything like that that you
can do helps us it moves everything
around in the algorithms and lets people
out there in the land of YouTube and
podcast know that we're there if we're
listening if you're listening on your
local radio station thank you for that
tell people that we're there on talk
radio 680 talk radio stations right now
thank you very much and even uh TBN
we're on TBN every day so if you get
that app or you're watching that on your
cable provider either one thank you
thank you for hanging out wherever you
are and help us spread the word and
leave a festar review say something nice
saying something nice on the internet
that would be cool that' be that' be a
new thing to say something nice on the
internet ah Jacob is in Fort Worth Texas
hi Jacob how are
you doing well sir how you doing better
than I deserve what's
up hey I was just calling because uh
obviously I enjoy listening to you and U
respect your opinion but my fiance and I
we're looking to move from Fort Worth
back to our home state of Minnesota cool
and so I was looking to get your opinion
about kind of what to look for when
buying our first home and um looking at
like a a fix upper versus a house that's
already in like Prestige shape uh maybe
in a growing Market our idea is that
we're not going to be here forever or in
that home so we're looking to grow
Equity um in the smartest way possible
fiance did you say
fiance yes sir yeah not fiance 9 yeah
when are you getting
married um we keep pushing it off we've
been engaged for about two years but we
uh originally from Minnesota we moved
down to Kansas City for two years and
then we moved to Fort Worth kind of on a
whim and then decided so we're hoping to
get married at the end of next year but
our goal is to buy a home first
don't do not buy a home with someone
you're not married
to you're going to get yourself into
legal relational spiritual and financial
trouble don't do it
don't do it I talked to a g a gal
yesterday that called me she had been
living with a guy for8
years they had two cars in their names
four credit cards in their names and a
house in their names and he
left you know what she is
screwed she can't get she can't sell any
of it cuz he won't sign the titles to
any of it he won't pay the payments on
any of it so she's being forced into
bankruptcy because of this right here
don't do this go to see the preacher and
get your butt married before you buy a
house okay cuz you're going to get in a
mess dude you're going to get in a
serious mess don't do that I've been
doing this 30 years all I've heard is
pain around this subject no one ever
gets blessed by what you're trying to do
here don't do it please don't do it now
once you get up there and you're married
because you're going to go get married
this weekend now and you know it's her
you'all been together two years so I'm
like just get the license you guys are
married you're acting like you're
married you're basically married painter
get off the ladder you got this jacob I
believe in you I debated about that um
you know part of it was going to get our
license like you like you just said and
then all the other part of me was
thinking about like it was her special
day so I kind of wanted everything to
happen at once yeah but our goal is to
this is our biggest investment and we're
not looking to you know a lot of people
take out loans and they have these uh
fancy weddings that cost so much money
but that's not really what we're looking
for um for the long game but it is still
her special day yeah it is her special
day so don't screw it up with buying a
house before the special day and then y
all have no special
days definitely definitely so you
recommend um you know like just going to
get a simple license or I don't care I
mean y'all figure it out figure out what
what the point is what our special day
looks like but I would not put your name
on a deed with someone that you are not
married to you're creating what your
attorney would tell you is called a
general partnership with no general
partnership
documents and so and I've seen all kinds
of horrible things happen to people in
these situations some of them are just
mean some of them are sad but it just
it's a mess I one guy his fiance got
killed now and there was no will she got
killed in a car wreck and now he owns a
house with her
mother talk about
yeah talk about awkward that's a mess so
don't do that no okay now so y'all
figure out how whether you know how
you're going to get married but before
you're Mar before you buy a house
together get married now let's pretend
you're married and then we'll answer
your question if you're brand new
married I would not buy a fixer upper
fixer uppers are hard work it's tough
it's distracting I would want you to
focus on each other and be in love
instead of hanging curtains and
peeling old old wallpaper off because
let me say this it it's s it's
romanticized on
HGTV it feels like oh my gosh we're
going to fix this house up and get what
we want all of it and it does end up
being usually more expensive the time
frame is longer you're dealing with
contractors or trying to I mean you it's
a second job is basically what that is
and so for your first year of marriage
you live in dust Perpetual dust it's
dust it's not some people do it well but
it sounds a whole lot better than the
actual reality of it there there there's
nothing good about it I've renovated one
house while I lived in it it's a disas
I'm sitting in a lawn chair right on
plywood floors cuz everything's ripped
up watching the Super Bowl one time I
told Sharon I said you might be a
redneck if you're sitting in your own
house inside in a lawn chair on a
plywood floor watching the Super Bowl
that's what renovating a house is it
ain't chipping Joanna I'm just telling
you nobody's hair is done the makeup's
not right it's all bad okay there's no
reality in reality TV HGTV has ruined
your perception of this thing so no I
would not do a fixer upper not my first
house if you're going to do a fixer
upper don't live in it while you're
doing it live somewhere else fix it up
over there then move in it if you want
to do a if you want to get some Equity
from some work being done it can be a
little little bit of light work like
we've got to do we got to tear all the
Landscaping out and we got to run a coat
of paint through the thing that's okay
but this idea we're going to knock down
walls and and you know The Decorator is
going to prance through and tell you no
no and the kitchen no you're killing me
no don't please now your expectation
though may have to lower that depending
on what you guys can afford you know
that it won't be this topof the line
either though right so like there's a
there's a a medium there of like yeah
but that's a good point I I forget that
These reality shows that aren't reality
that have nothing to do with they're
scripted as they can be um and the
hilarious thing is people in the
industry call them unscripted TV but
they're about they're more scripted than
a dad gum sitcom and then and they've
romanticized it make because you know
between commercial breaks the whole
thing gets
done and and it no it's eight months
later and you're still sucking drywall
dust while you're trying to sleep you
know it's just it's nasty I grew up in
the construction business I've done
probably, 1500 rehabs in my life I used
to do it for a living you don't want to
do that it's not it's not what TV
portrays it to be you're right about
that I had thought had not thought about
that part of the problem sounds dreamy
and romantic yeah it's not it's not
funny yeah um I I I know it's shocking
to you people but those people on The
Bachelor could have got a date without
the TV show it's shocking I know but um
yeah it's it's if they were really
looking to not be a bachelor it probably
could have worked it out but um so
without any anyway so yeah that that's
funny Rachel's favorite show is that
your favorite show still H it's moved on
to the Real
Housewives we can talk reality TV
another day Dave you will not like my
reality TV no I don't like any reality
TV and the Kardashians new Season's out
you know I love it I think it's all
fantastic you are so culturally relevant
I think I that I am that I am you kept
mentioning Tiger King even like six
months ago I was like oh Dave no one
watches that anymore no I mean a thing
that was a thing during the fou
pandemic we the F pic we watch Tiger
King yeah but love is blind talks a lot
about money there's a lot of
conversations around it none of it makes
sense yeah all right there we go you
never know uh good luck Jacob I hope it
works out for you my brother uh sorry
you're called in and got a speech but I
don't want I don't want bad things for
you I I love you I want you to win you
see how growing up oh yeah that's what
Rachel got at the dinner a living room
still in counseling for it this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is our
co-host today open phones atle
225 one of the things we love looking
outside the windows of our Studios
seeing all the people in the lobby as
we're doing our show it's on from 1 to 4
Central Time every day and people come
from all over and sit and watch the show
get free homemade cookies and free
coffee and the second thing we love is
there's a debt free stage and people
come in and we do their debt free
screams and the best debt free screams
of all are those that work on our team
so an actual ramsy team member is ready
to do a debt free scream with a better
than I deserve t-shirt on I mean you
you're wearing the colors and everything
I love it so Tracy and Brian Tracy cus
is our one of our leadership team here
she's a newly minted leader on our team
and is a senior director of supply chain
uh Logistics which means she makes the
world go around around here and her
husband Brian and uh here to do a
debt-free scream congratulations you two
congrats thanks Dave thanks Rachel so
you've been here about what 3 or four
months right uh it was 90 days last week
oh wow okay very cool good good Brian
what do you do sheat metal awesome very
cool that's a great trade and doing good
right now I bet oh yeah yeah I bet yeah
booming yeah good for you
congratulations so uh how much debt did
you two pay off
$462,000 goodness my gosh Tracy and how
long did this take 48 months 48 months
wow all right and we don't ask your
income since your team members are all
standing around here uh that would be a
little bit a awkward so uh we're not
going to do that but um uh what kind of
debt was this uh everything student
loans credit cards uh 401K loans
consolidation debt uh you name it we had
it a leas car um yeah wow and our house
okay and and and our house and our house
as she says it as a passing okay and you
paid off your home yes okay so tell us
the story what happened because I know
you you guys moved here to take this
position I remember that when you were
coming in and um so you moved here and
how did this all go down um about in the
end of 2018 I took a new position um at
my previous company um in supply chain
and um I uh was it had switched the time
that I was listening to someone else on
the radio and on Sirus X them and my
nice leased car and I uh it was at the
end of the day so I wasn't listening to
her anymore and you came on cuz she had
switched channels and um I was like
who's this guy from that has this accent
you know from the south I don't know who
this guy is but he's talk asking people
questions that you're not supposed to
ask people you're not supposed to ask
people how much they make you're not
supposed to ask people you know how much
debt they have and you're not supposed
to ask them all these personal questions
it's like this taboo thing and everybody
was just telling you all this
information and you weren't shaming them
for anything or well I mean sometimes
you're hard on them but you weren you
weren't like shaming them you were like
kind to them and trying to help them um
have hope and um earlier that year I had
received the largest um bonus I had ever
received at my previous company and I
took it it was $118,000 and I took it I
paid off all my credit cards and by the
time I was listening to you it was
already back up to 12,000 wow and we um
were not uh doing our budgets to we
weren't doing our finances together um
we got married at a later um age in life
and we decided that you know we don't
need to do our finances together um and
then you were saying that we did and so
um anyway so a couple weeks later I got
your Total Money Makeover book listen to
it in like a couple days um and then I
came to him and I said hey um I think we
should do this plan and uh and know by
the way I have like like a ton of debt
and um he didn't know um
so that's where it started so Brian uh
she had to tell you how much debt how
much debt did you have was all of it
yours uh most of it was mine um he h
would you have a credit card and like a
small student loan that you're hanging
on to yeah a few credit cards with
whatever one to two grand on them a
piece or something so she tells you
there's this pile of debt what did you
do go holy crap yep she's like you want
to work together you're like NOP they
got doing pretty good no I don't thank
you it it was it was tough to put it all
in one pot I bet for sure yes a lot of
couples feel that uhhuh so what did you
think though Brian when she's like okay
I want to work I do want to work
together let's com let's let's do the
subject as a married couple together
what was your because are you more of
the spender saver like what's y Dynamic
she's the spender I can tell by the debt
well I guess I don't want to always Mark
I don't want to Mark Spenders like that
I'm not Guiltless but I'll uh yeah I
usually do my research yeah and plan it
and save it and then do it anyway but
not just do it and then pay it off later
because if you can't afford it you don't
buy it exactly so that was in 2018 so
did you guys start pretty immediately
together in that or pretty much I think
we we started looking at the budget um
back in the day you used to have to hand
write the budget and it was driving me
nuts um and so but I took brought one to
him and I said hey why don't you do this
mock budget and see how much you think
you're spending and I'll see how much I
think I'm spending and that was kind of
what opened the door for us to see that
um we were just we weren't telling each
other when we were going to the grocery
store I'm buying bread he's buying bread
everybody's buying bread or I'm buying
steak he's buying Lobster or whatever um
so uh yeah and so in um 2019 we started
FPU and um and then we just started you
know hammering the debt and um I paid
off the we paid off the uh the lease 9
months early and turned it in early and
I got my hoop D MH and what's funny
about that is you know God has a sense
of humor because when I went to get the
title for my hoopie um they gave me the
license plate and said BMW on
it and it was not a BMW it's not it's
not it's not a BMW it's a 19989 Toyota
Sara uh yeah so we did the plan um it
only it we actually did it pretty
quickly um we got our uh emergency fund
in place and um so you're debt free
everything but the house yeah we're debt
free everything but the house in 2020 Co
hit and he went out of work and instead
of us being freaked out we we were
relaxed and we actually invested in a a
Roth IRA for him um two years in a row
and we did really well that year cuz uh
everybody was freaking out about coid
Investments and we just listened to what
you had to say and we were like well
let's just see what happens and it went
through the roof so it was cool yeah um
and then um through that Journey um we
because of that we became um we started
believing in Jesus again um or I started
believing in Jesus again and what God
could do and I brought brought him along
um and through that my dad um also came
to know Jesus before he passed away wow
wow wow it's a big story
yeah with so much and then you guys move
here to take the job and sell the house
back home yep we we we moved here um
sold the house and took we just decided
that God blessed us with enough equity
that um we should be able to buy a house
with cash and so that's what we did when
we got here so we are 100% debt free and
it's awesome what a great story Tracy
and Brian that's amazing boom well we're
proud to have you on the team but we're
proud of you too both of you both of you
absolutely incredible yeah uh man
there's a lot going on there in 48
months a lot happening in your lives and
uh it's very cool very cool we're so
happy you you're here part of this team
you're obviously very skilled at what
you do um here within your discipline
but uh everybody has also embraced you
immediately as a team member and as a
key part of the leadership team so
congratulations and way to go y'all how
it feel to not have a payment in the
world fantastic
fantastic amen awesome Amen well way to
go you guys all right Tracy cus our
senior director of supply chain her
husband Brian
$462,000 paid in 48 months and two
people walking with Jesus count it down
let's hear a debt free Scream 3 two one
we're debt free
yeah that's how that's done
wow wow a lot happen I wish we had a
whole other segment with them I'm like
there's so many questions I want to ask
they're incredible oh my gosh incredible
well done this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Philippians 4:8
finally brothers and sisters whatever is
true whatever is Noble whatever is right
whatever is pure whatever is lovely
whatever is admirable if anything is
excellent or praiseworthy think about
such
things Bobby Knight said the key is not
the will to win everybody has that it is
the will to prepare to win that is
important well rest in peace Bobby
Knight we lost him this week open phones
here at
88255 22
Alex is in Norfolk Virginia hi Alex how
are
you hi Dave I'm doing good how about you
better than I deserve what's
up uh so last night my wife turned to me
before bed and told me that she didn't
feel satisfied at work anymore and that
it it was causing her too much stress
and it just wasn't what she expected
when she joined the the job she works as
a a social
worker um
while she's waiting to save up to go
into her master's so she can become a
clinical
psychologist um she moved here about
three years ago when uh we came here to
Virginia and she she's had plenty of
jobs since then but they've never lasted
longer than about six months before she
would either find a better job or uh
maybe they had a agreement at work or
um she couldn't take the job
anymore and we're we're in the middle of
paying off the student loans from uh
from her psychology
degree and we just found out
that um my wife is pregnant like a month
ago so congratulations it's all kind of
hitting me all thank you it's all kind
of hitting me all at once I'm very
excited about the B
but I was very I was very collected when
she told me about it she was surprised
and I told her it's because we're
financially stable we're on a plan I
don't have to worry about knowing if
we're going to be able to afford the
baby or not because I know that we can
but if she's moving if if she's planning
on moving to a different job that it
shakes my my um my structure I guess
like it it shakes my rock I don't have I
don't I know that we can get by on my
income but buy with a
baby I make I'm in the Navy I make
uh I I make 4 4,200 a month okay $50,000
year what does she make she
makes 23 a month okay $30,000 a year
okay yep and we put 3,000 towards her
debt every month how much student loan
debt is
uh
57 that's what it was last month
57,000 yes
oh yeah is that y'all's only debt
Alex yes we thought it was a lot less
than that until she graduated and we
looked at the numbers and it was twice
that twice of what you thought okay yeah
exactly um what do you think not to like
psycho analyze her but what what's the
with the job changes that are pretty
consistent with her what what do you
think the what do you think the thing is
about
that so her the reoccurring thing is she
doesn't Find meaning in her work when
she works somewhere that she finds
meaning at then she she never complains
about it and she hasn't complained about
this job for she she's been there six
months now she hasn't complained about
it until the last um two months she she
would she started mentioning that she
was tired of training she's been
training on the computer ever since she
got to the job and every time they give
her opportunity to come forth and like
do something that's actually deals with
social work um she like trips or fumbles
or doesn't get something right and uh
then somebody gets upset with her she's
got some rude
co-workers and then she I think she just
can't handle it and she brought up that
um a lady called her that was supposed
to have called her a month ago so that
they could fix something but then they
now they couldn't fix it because she
didn't call when she was supposed to and
she got cussed out over the phone and
she wanted the job so she could help
people and she doesn't feel like she's
helping people she feels like people are
getting angry at her for trying to
help okay how old is
she uh
23 okay um
what what what what can we do to
help um I just I I want to know I I want
her to be happy in her work I don't I I
love listening to the Kim Coleman show
and I believe in like working at
something that you feel passionate about
and I want her to feel passionate about
what she does but I I'm scared because
so much is going on right now and she
wants to make this choice I want to back
her in whatever she wants but I want to
make sure that we're doing the right
thing yeah okay um there's two reasons
that we work one is to self-actualize
and have purpose and meaning in our work
and do work that matters and that
certainly needs to be the long-term goal
all right the second reason we work is
we're grown-ups and we have to feed our
family and you suck it up and put a
callous on your hand and you do the
work that's the two reasons you work now
here's the point what Ken Coleman is
telling people and what we tell people
here and have for 30 years is uh you
don't suck it up for 38 years you suck
it up for 38 months but she has never
once sucked it up she has never once
stiffened her backbone and walked
through a tough time every time the wind
blows she goes out the door that's who
you've described to us for the past few
minutes
and so she has a baby on the way and
$57,000 in debt this is when you suck it
up if somebody's mean to you oh well
welcome welcome to the world deal with
it suck it up she is a she has a um she
has some problems with anxiety and she
wants to be a
psychologist yes
sir okay we're going to have to do
something she's going to have to at 23
years old she's going to have to develop
some toughness to be able to be a mommy
and to be a grownup and uh I'm not
saying anxiety is not real and I'm not
saying just pretend like you're not
anxious that's not the point if she
needs to see a counselor fine let's see
a counselor but but this idea that every
time it gets rough at work we quit
you're never going to keep a job in your
whole life I own this place and some
days I hate
it and I can do anything I want to do
but I do it anyway and Alex I think the
and I think the hard thing what you're
going to have to discover is you can't
control her as much as you want it for
her she has to want it herself and her
own journey of understanding herself and
why she is the way she is why we all are
right we all have to get to that point
where we're like okay what what has
caused me to have these patterns in my
life the wakeup call has to come from
her it can't come from you wanting her
to have it and that's going to be a
tough position that you're in Alex
you're calling the show for her
let me ask you something has she got
brothers and
sisters no she's an only child I thought
so okay and so she's her daddy's little
princess isn't she uh no she had U dad
problems oh okay so he he left he left
the picture halfway through okay all
right um cuz this uh it it sounds like
that um a lot of hurt she has a lot
she's functioning out of she deal with a
lot of hurtt and a lot of when she feels
rejection she bounces Alex probably from
what you just told us in the last 30
seconds from her story I mean there's a
lot of her stor she has to become aware
of for her to heal and become a whole
person and not to so I so part of me is
like I understand why she's doing it but
it's doesn't make it okay and so it puts
you in a tough position and so you're
going to have to sit down and have a and
you guys have to lay out these numbers
and just say hey for the next nine
months because when you have a baby
depending on what you want to do like we
have to be in this we have to we have to
figure out a way to pay down this debt
so that we're not drowning financially
and you you need to be and I want and I
want you as your husband I'm seeing this
pain longterm I want you be yes I want
her to be longterm I want her to be in
something she loves and where she's
helping people and where she's not
having to deal with toxic work
co-workers I don't I don't blame her for
that longterm I want her to be there but
short term we got to be a grown-up we
got a baby to baby to feed we got debt
to pay off and um and we probably do
need to get to the bottom of from a
psychological standpoint why we're
studying psychology and get into this
that puts us our the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
yeah